Okay, I hope you're enjoying the course so far.
Here's an exercise that'll give you a chance to do
some data wrangling using the XLRD module in Python.
What I'd like you to do here, is read through
the aircot hourly load file. This file here, and report the time stamp,
which is stored in this column, and load for the min, max, and
average values from this column. From the coast region of Texas. Let's
quickly take a look at the code provided. What I'd
like you to look at first are the assertions here
at the bottom. This gives you an idea for the
type of values you need to produce. What I'd like you
to do here, is find the max value in that
column B, the coast region. And then, for that max
value, find the value on column to the left where
the time stamp is stored. And report it as a tuple,
just like we did when we were looking at our example of how
to use XLRD. In order to complete this exercise, you'll be working in
the Parse File function. And you need to pull out values that will
allow you to complete this data dictionary
right here, which is going to be returned.